what is up everyone I'm Ilana and I am
at South by Southwest in Austin Texas to
review ready player one right now I'm
heading to an event where they're
showing off of a game that I'm gonna try
out and just like a bunch of cool kind
of sets so I'll take a quick look at
that and then we'll get into reviewing
the movie because it is an interesting
one
[Music]
since I booked my thousand dollar plane
flights and it's so much contact with
one of Rose P I being like hey guys can
I get a ticket to the movie when's the
movie I'm flying here just to review
this movie what's the situation and they
were all super lovely but one a lot to
say anything because it was supposed to
be a surprise
I only just got my ticket and found out
when and where this movie is actually
taking place I have not read ready
player one but I made that as a very
intentional decision I decided that I'm
going to review the movie having not
read the book and then I'm going to go
back and read the book and review it
again so to be like two reviews
[Music]
and now it's my pleasure to introduce
the director
[Applause]
you are the first public audience in the
entire world to experience
oh my god we just got out of the movie
I'm gonna call heading home right now
but so the movie cut out um right
towards the end the audio cut for about
15 seconds everyone in the audience I
thought it was intentional for a bit and
then realized it wasn't and then they
tried to restart it the same thing
happen again and then they finally got
it working on the third time but holy
[ __ ] that's weird it's a very very
different experience and you know it's
even weird for me having to like write
my shitty notes and they're all scribbly
because I can't see what I'm writing I
wrote all of this there are no spoilers
hey nobody worried in the dark so it's
what happened this situation what's all
this already you guys I made it back to
the apartment it's already 120 because
of course daylight savings [ __ ]
kicked in I lost an hour of writing
already but yeah I really want to talk
about people were cheering in the
theatres Steven Spielberg was there you
know people stood up and applauded and
even when it paused which was insane
people cheered when it came back on it
it's it's such a positive environment
being completely honest I felt like this
bias there that I'm gonna try as hot as
possible to like get rid of but I feel
like it's an undeniable reality of
seeing a movie in this kind of thing
that movie reviewers must have to deal
with all the time of course I'm going to
try and cut through it pretend it's not
a thing I'm just saying subconsciously I
imagine people influenced by that
environment by it being exciting and
hyped up and by everyone around them
having such a good time that it like
kind of mess me up a little bit like it
seems wrong so let's get into talking
about the actual movie here you guys I
did really enjoy it
it's a lot funnier than I thought it
would be and that was my favorite thing
about it I loft so many times and I will
also totally admit to finding a lot of
the references really satisfying that
said there's plenty of [ __ ] wrong with
it the characters have pretty much no
development some lines are really really
cheesy like a literal quote that I
rolled my eyes at was a character
seriously on ironically saying a fan
bully knows a hater there are like
30-second backstories for some
characters that is supposed to be sad
that had just brought up and then never
mentioned again to the extent that it's
like well why did you even do this so
it's ultimately like a thing that's fun
to watch but not all that well thought
out like just a popcorn action
another thing is the the real wells
outside of the Oasis just has all these
questions that don't get answered that
I'm sure will get answered in the book
but it's it's like they just didn't even
bother explaining it and the first like
I don't know maybe 10 minutes of the
film I'm probably exaggerating that are
just exposition meaning it's just like
video footage with voiceover over the
top explaining things and they couldn't
even think to explain the actual goddamn
Oasis I do think people are really going
to enjoy watching it when they're not
approaching it as a critic right now I'm
thinking I'm gonna give it a 7 or an 8
and 8 on IG and scale means great and I
don't think it's a great movie I think
it's it's like a pretty good movie it's
somewhere in between the two it is 4:30
a.m. and I finally finished writing this
took a lot longer than normal for a
review for me because it's just so much
of trying to remember the thing that I
only had an hour and a half with but
I've sent the review off to my editor
back in San Francisco and then I have to
wake up at 9 a.m. San Francisco time to
review the edits and record via good
morning everyone I'm gonna close it I
woke up and had all the notes ready from
the editors back in San Francisco and LA
and I'm now sitting in this closet to
record VR the way that this kind of
stuff works is you don't have a
soundproof room you have to pull a
blanket over your head so we're gonna be
recording kind of like this with a
microphone so let's do it
while I'll admit to catching myself
smiling at familiar pop-culture
references probably 20 times during my
screening of ready player one it is more
than just a cameo fest okay
vo has been recorded I've just been
breathing in the scent of humans shoes
so let's get out of here
I just need to finish the written
version now got some notes that's
basically they want me to talk more
about the acting which I guess I didn't
touch on because I didn't have a ton to
say about it and also just how it
compares to other Spielberg films so I'm
gonna add that stuff in and hopefully
have it up very soon well I'll admit to
catching myself smiling at familiar
pop-culture references probably 20 times
during my screening of ready player one
it is alrighty everyone it is all up now
now come the comment to people telling
me that my review is paid off somehow
with a 7.5 because it's not a Disney
movie I don't get it thank you guys all
so much for watching I'll see you next
time